bonjour à tous bienvenue sur votre
chaîne devait libération politique
la chaîne qui vous explique la politique
française en quelques minutes
aujourd'hui on va parler de la
constitution la vie en société c'est
jamais très facile et ça c'est pas
nouveau c'est toujours plein de gens qui
se dispute pour un oui ou pour un non et
pour organiser tout ce petit monde
toutes les sociétés ont des normes qui
dicte les règles à suivre définissent
les droits et les devoirs
la société française qui est constituée
elle aussi de plein de gens qui dispute
les français donc ne déroge pas à la
règle des normes françaises
vous en connaissez déjà si vous suivez
bien cette chaîne vous connaissez les
lois et les écrits si vous nous suivez
sur facebook ou twitter
vous connaissez aussi les ordonnances et
si vous vous abonnez vous verrez plus
tard les circulaires et les arrêter
toutes ces normes sont organisés
hiérarchiquement est tout en haut
la norme suprême c'est la constitution
c'est la règle de droit que doivent
respecter toutes les autres normes au
sein d'une nation ni une loi ni un
décret ni quoi que ce soit ne peut venir
contredire la constitution la première
constitution française date après la
révolution mais des règles pour
organiser la société
il y en a toujours eu sous l'ancien
régime donc à l'époque des rois les
normes suprême étaient les lois
fondamentales du royaume
elle servait à définir non seulement
l'étendue et les limites du pouvoir du
roi les règles d'héritage du royaume
mais aussi les libertés fondamentales
des personnes et des communautés
mais la révolution française tout a
changé
et du coup les normes aussi ont changé
en écrivant la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen on a redéfini la
norme suprême en l'appelant constitution
et en la définissant comme ça toute
société dans laquelle la garantie des
droits n'est pas assurée ni la
séparation des pouvoirs déterminée n'a
point de constitution dans cette simple
phrase il ya tout les sens de la
constitution la garantie des droits et
la séparation des pouvoirs législatif
judiciaire et exécutif
c'est une grande différence avec les
lois fondamentales qui elles définissent
et des privilèges et qui laissait les
pouvoirs entre les mains d'un seul homme
le roi la première constitution
française date de 1791 et met en place
une monarchie parlementaire
comme vous pouvez le retrouver en
angleterre à chaque fois qu'on change de
constitution on change de régime
donc de façon d'organiser l'état mais
c'est pas parce qu'on est à la 5ème
république qui ne veulent que cinq
constitutions depuis la révolution
on a déjà vu que la première a mis en
place une monarchie parlementaire mais
d'autres constitutions ont mis en place
le directoire le premier empire
le consulat et c'est notre constitution
française actuelle date de 1958 c'est de
gaulle qui l'a proposé et mis en place
après avoir demandé leur avis aux
français par référendum
on s'imagine souvent le texte de la
constitution comme casse-tête très
juridique est difficile à lire
mais en vrai c'est un texte plutôt
facile à comprendre et à ses cours une
quarantaine de pages seulement je vous
conseille vraiment de la lire c'est très
instructif
mais si vous avez la flemme pas de
problème abonnez-vous juste à cette
chaîne
vu que dans nos vidéos on parle d'à peu
près tout ce qui est dans la
constitution la constitution n'est pas
un seul grand texte mais c'est un groupe
de texte elle est composée de ses
propres articles bien sûr mais aussi de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de 1789 qui définit les
droits fondamentaux de chaque individu
il est aussi le préambule de la
constitution de 1946 qui définit les
grands principes de la république et qui
améliore certaines libertés et droits
par rapport aux droits de l'homme comme
par exemple l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
et enfin on retrouve la charte de
l'environnement qui définit les droits
et les devoirs fondamentaux qui concerne
la protection de l'environnement les
articles de la constitution se répartit
en un préambule et 16 grande partie
qu'on appelle titre chaque
décrit une partie de l'organisation du
pays par exemple le titre a un parent de
la souveraineté du pays et définit la
langue nationale
les couleurs du drapeau l'hymne national
et c'est le titre de parle du président
de la république
le titre iii c'est le gouvernement le 4
c'est le parlement etc
dans son ensemble la constitution décrit
la façon dont fonctionne l'état et les
institutions
on y retrouve la nature de l'état on dit
que la france est un état unitaire donc
que tous les citoyens sont soumis aux
mêmes pouvoirs mais elle pourrait être
un état fédéral comme en allemagne qui
possède 16 lander autonome on y retrouve
aussi le régime politique parlementaire
dans lequel le pouvoir exécutif est
représenté par le gouvernement
présidentielle où le pouvoir exécutif
est détenu par le président ou semi
présidentiel comme en france où le
pouvoir exécutif est partagé entre
président et gouvernement la
constitution décrit aussi la façon de
désigner ceux qui gouvernent l'élection
du chef de l'état la nomination du
premier ministre etc
enfin elle décrit les compétences des
gouvernants qui dirige qui juge qu' et
qui légifèrent la constitution exprime
aussi un certain nombre de valeurs comme
l'égalité entre les hommes posent un
certain nombre de principes comme la
souveraineté nationale et décline un
certain nombre de droits comme la
liberté d'expression la constitution
évolué au fil du temps et régulièrement
modifié car la france a changé depuis
1958 et il est important que les normes
s'y adapte pour modifier la constitution
on utilise les lois constitutionnelles
elles sont plus importantes que les lois
ordinaires et subissent un traitement
particulier et parmi les révisions
constitutionnelles majeur il ya par
exemple l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel direct
avant 1962 il était élu par un collège
de grands électeurs comme les sénateurs
aujourd'hui on note aussi le passage de
la durée du mandat présidentiel de sept
ans à 5 ans certains transferts de
souveraineté vers l'union européenne
l'ajout de la charte de l'environnement
et plein d'autres choses encore
donc la constitution est au dessus de
tout et c'est au conseil constitutionnel
de s'assurer qu'elle est respectée le
conseil constitutionnel est une
institution constitué de neuf membres
qui vérifie la conformité de la loi à la
constitution la conformité des élections
nationales et qui peut être saisie par
n'importe quel citoyen s'ils pensent
qu'une loi est inconstitutionnelle
vous trouverez plus d'informations sur
le conseil constitutionnel dans la vidéo
qui lui est dédié la petite image que
vous voyez là est tiré de notre page
facebook où l'on explique simplement la
politique non pas à travers des vidéos
comme ici mais avec des petites
infographie pensez à y faire un tour
donc voilà tout est dit vous aurez donc
compris que la constitution est la norme
française au dessus de toutes les autres
normes et que en gros elle contient deux
choses l'organisation des instances
dirigeantes en séparant les pouvoirs et
les droits et libertés des individus
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que maintenant vous comprenez
bien à quoi sert la constitution est ce
qu'il ya dedans
n'hésitez pas à liker partager la vidéo
est à nous laisser vos commentaires
pensez à aussi aller faire un tour sur
notre page facebook
notre compte twitter on publie très
régulièrement des petits infographie
comme celle sur le conseil
constitutionnel pour répondre à des
questions simples en une seule image
merci pour votre visionnage et à très
bientôt